okay so this video is gonna be on
carbohydrates and some of the chemistry
behind them so let's get started so when
it comes to carbohydrates they are one
of the four categories of organic
molecules carbohydrates you know are our
high in our our high in certain foods
such as breads pastas fruits you know
the other categories of organic
molecules
you know proteins eggs are high in
proteins and the phospholipid bilayer in
the picture
you know surrounds every cell and so
lipids is another category of organic
molecule and nucleic acids such as DNA
and organic molecules are our molecules
built around carbon now this video is
only going to discuss carbohydrates I
have others if you want to learn the
characteristics of proteins and lipids
and nucleic acids so when it comes to
carbohydrates you know some of them are
used for energy purposes for instance
glucose in the picture there is the
chemical structure of glucose glucose is
produced as a result of photosynthesis
and it's then broken down during
cellular respiration in order to make
adenosine triphosphate ATP the energy
molecule of our cells and other
carbohydrates are used to build they're
used for structure for instance the
green cell wall of plants is made from a
carbohydrate called cellulose and so
this is a structural carbohydrate
cellulose used to build the outer layer
called the cell wall of plants another
structural carbohydrate is called chitin
you know the exoskeleton of insects and
crustaceans is made from a carbohydrate
a structural carbohydrate called chitin
so carbohydrates are made from carbon
hydrogen and oxygen in a one to two to
one ratio for instance in glucose you
can see glucose has 12 hydrogen's but
only six carbons and six oxygens has
twice as many hydrogen's as carbon and
oxygen you can also see that in fruit
now notice that glucose and fructose
have the exact same formula c6h12o6 you
might be wondering how are they
different well the 24 atoms are arranged
in a different configuration molecules
like this that have the same formula but
are arranged a bit differently are
called isomers so glucose and fructose
are good examples of isomers now if you
know the 1 to 2 to 1 ratio if I were to
give you this question pretend a
carbohydrate has 4 carbons
how many hydrogens and oxygens would it
contain I hope you would know the answer
would be 8 hydrogen's and 4 oxygens
so when you study organic molecules
you're gonna hear a lot about monomers
and polymers and an analogy of a monomer
it's an a monomer first of all is a
simple organic molecule it's a building
block you know such as a brick but when
you combine a bunch of bricks you have
not what's called a monomer but a
polymer and in this case you know a
brick wall so we're gonna be showing you
how monomers are used to construct
polymers as we go through carbohydrates
and if you watch some of my other videos
on organic molecules so here are the
categories of monomers and polymers now
this video is only going to really touch
on the bottom the monomers called
monosaccharides and the polymers called
a polysaccharide so first of all
monosaccharides are the monomers of
carbohydrates they're the building
blocks glucose is a great example of a
monomer of a monosaccharide it's a
simple sugar and glucose will often bond
with other monosaccharides to form
complex sugars and before I go any
further I do want to mention that the
word saccharide is Greek for sugar so
sugars are carbohydrates so here is a
very simplistic drawing of let's say
glucose the hexagon shape and when for
instance one monosaccharide barnes with
another monosaccharide this is
holiday dye saccharide dye is a prefix
that means two so two mono
monosaccharides have been binded
together but when multiple
monosaccharides bind together this is
what is called a polysaccharide you know
these are the complex sugars examples of
this would be starch and glycogen and
cellulose which we're gonna go into more
detail in a few moments so let's look at
some polysaccharides in a little more
detailed polysaccharides again remember
our long chain of monosaccharides now
the one pictured is the polysaccharide
called starch starch is a plant
polysaccharide now you know plants do
photosynthesis and they make glucose but
sometimes they make more glucose than
they use so they want to store that
glucose so the glucose is will bond
through dehydration synthesis into
starch and for simplicity you can see
that I've shown this picture right here
so here's some glucose is bonded
together and as time goes by these
starches the starch molecule can be
broken down and the energy can be
released as the plant me as the plant
has its cellular needs starches are high
in various foods such as you know rice
is high in starch and you know breads
are high in starch and potatoes are high
in starch
you know another polysaccharide I want
to mention is the animal version of
starch and that's a polysaccharide
called glycogen and glycogen is a way
that animals can store energy that
hasn't been used so when glucose is you
know consumed in our in our diet in our
food and and broken down we will then
have that leftover glucose that maybe
wasn't used and those glucoses will be
bonded into glycogen and in fact
glycogen is this enormous molecule over
30,000 glucose monomers make up a
glycogen molecule called glycogen and so
these glycogen czar often stored in our
liver
and then are broken down throughout the
day as needed and then another
polysaccharide dimension is cellulose
cellulose is a structural polysaccharide
it's you know in the picture here we
have the yellow cell membrane or plasma
membrane this is the the semipermeable
layer of the cell that allows material
in and out and then there is the green
cell wall that is pictured here now the
cell wall of plants is made from from a
polysaccharide called cellulose and for
instance you know this explains why you
know celery is so tough and fibrous
celery is packed full of cellulose and
you know we have a real hard time
digesting foods that have a lot of
cellulose in them because we don't
possess enzymes to break down cellulose
we are we actually break down you for
instance celery because we have
microscopic bacteria that live inside of
our digestive tract that are able to do
it for us since we don't possess the
enzymes to do it ourselves so there you
have it you know if you're in my class
pause the video try to answer these
questions you know write them down on a
separate sheet of paper I'm happy to
check your answers before class or after
class one day so I'll leave your
comments in the box below and thanks for
watching